viel spaß wie hin und wünschte ihnen
doppelt grill sondern viele jüngere die
wälder brennen soll
17 cents
binz uns also sogar hin und weg sind sie
denn gehen und mit kleinerem bildschirm
ja ich kann vor allem letzte wort
[Musik]
die kalorien
warum
wohin duft warteten dass das land den
schweizer und ein portugiese kretlow
shifting rasch offroader abholen und
ross und roskow der strooss den bereich
robert inhalt prostituierte sehen oder
also quasi wie cindy richtig oder ist
das eine alle japaner namens telefon
krieg klose wenn zuspruch unter die
gürtellinie gibt das eingreift ist lernt
sie kämpft für ihre liebe um englisch
gegen überflüssige kilos 13 minuten für
100 kalorien
ich muss unbedingt abnehmen
für miami beach muss ich wie der
schlanke und hübsch werden oder wenn ich
zehn kilogramm schwere was sie tun womit
für tottenham
und der hesse wir nehmen den unter rund
108 arbeitsziel wäre schon jene vereine
wollen in zukunft wieder unnötig so ich
habe natürlich wenige ziehen auch gern
halten zu sagen
[Musik]
hier ist die wohnung also das ist jetzt
der ausblick von draußen das ist liegt
das ist dann das ist ja das ist ein
kanal
es war immer mein traum nach amerika zu
fliegen
wir hatten martins bildungsurlaub schon
vor anderthalb jahren geplant oder war
es war ja ich lebe schon so lange mit
martin dass ich immer glaube er könne
russisch als ob wir schon 50 und nicht
erst sechs jahre zusammen wären
ich freue mich sehr im frühling nach
miami zu reisen
ich bin stolz auf meinen mann dass er
uns als familie dieser reise an diesem
schönen ort ermöglicht nach 220 jahren
schule links grade martin bildungsurlaub
machen
sechs wochen sprachaufenthalt in den usa
alle sie spuren
es fällt nun aus visum für planer frau
aus heinsberg
[Musik]
der ev die schweiz also dass ich einfach
sensationell wenn du da auf der brust
wächst ein last minute dann kommt
vielleicht einmal als du musst ein hoher
geldbuße überhaupt grund oder zwischen
winterthur und zürich wird die stadt
winterthur und bayrischen stadt zürich
unter fans haben mich immer vier stunden
lang kaputt dann muss der finder waren
der busfahrer macht google music award
die homepage und dann muss stets ab
zählt in busse wie es kapiert automaten
dass sie machen es wird nicht einfach
[Musik]
kanadas läuft noch
sonja moor gefriert oder wohnquartier am
stadtrand fockbek fahre
[Musik]
minute sieht der thomas kley problem
ihrem radio sind die wetterprognose
gemacht hat jetzt laptops imam david und
bis in die schwiegereltern und das alles
macht thomas aus liebe zu dir ja genau
für dich sogar schnee da im
untergeschoss ist es also neue die haie
von thomas klein
das ist man anderswo sicherheit also
hellersdorf praktisch ist zu hell oder
je nach überhaupt keine stars sind da
die einzige fenster sowie schnee dafür
dass ich schwarz
ich würde es läuft das ist natürlich
teurer werden so storm meter schnee
es schaut jetzt wirklich viel besser aus
hier mehr unsers dienste des zählers es
ist jetzt unser ziel ja dass ich genau
das hat er david gemacht und ich in der
schweiz der hut sein
das ende des lieds und die schweiz haben
der wert dieses mal wechselt die
grundlage jeder integration ist die
sprache wie du deine umfeld schafft dein
humor wie du dich eingibst wie du
kontakt zu den leuten aufnimmt ich finde
auf die worte nicht was ich kann nicht
spielen mit der sprache vom dienst will
ich trage schon so eine diskussion ob
ich mal so mit medizinischer home ist
sicher schon mal verbieten
und dann war da nichts spruchreif ist
ironisch da muss der muss präzise
sprache und dann wäre das gar nicht mich
an humor und überbringen und wie sie
sich in luftige familie sie lachen viel
und ich einfach mit dazu beitragen dass
ich bin mir ist langweilig trachten
fluss
und neu besonderes frustrieren jetzt im
winter mit dem vielen schnee ist thomas
als passionierter velofahrer ruft
schmissen ohne eigenes auto geschrieben
ruf andrea krise zum 9
und so ist der ex metro mag so zieht
schnee schufa im hauptfach du mich dass
es nur witze schnittstelle ist auf brave
mädchen der piste alles geschmolzen ist
relativ
sie lernten redet kennen und waren alle
happy
vor allem mein vater als
stammesoberhaupt er war so angetan und
dankte ihr dass sie mir wieder auf die
beine geholfen hat was sagt er
als ob ich frauen schlagen würde sowas
würde ich nie tun
aber er sagte dass danke
[Gelächter]
sie schliesse crans-montana trickett und
jay sind unterwegs zum traditionellen
stammes fest mit tanz und musik erinnert
sich noch wie notkredits ihre familie
vorgestellt hat ich brachte sie ins haus
meiner eltern mein vater schien sie
sofort zu mögen
er hatte ein breites lachen und sagte
woher kommst du
sie sagte aus der schweiz
und er sagte toll und erzählte dass er
als junger mann um ein haar eine
schweizerin geheiratet hätte als in
europa militärdienst leistete und alles
war sofort wunderbar
[Musik]
brigitta heiligen ort
mini heimat ist schweiz also große
vertrautheit da jetzt wo wir schon
mancher dixie und midcaps langsam dass
sie bald ihre zelte abbrechen und die
schweiz übersiedelt
wir hatten uns entschieden in der
schweiz zu ziehen bevor tram gewährt
wurde
doch nun mussten wir darüber nachdenken
was die veränderungen für uns bedeuten
würden
denn es waren veränderungen die nicht
gut waren
das widerspricht den indianischen
prinzipien wir sind für mutter erde und
für das leben eines jeden und das
versuchte er zu zerstören er ist gegen
alles woran ich glaube
[Musik]
wir waren noch nicht mal verheiratet da
wollte er bereits ein papier
unterschreiben
für den fall einer scheidung
lehrlingslohn und du wirst dich jetzt
schon scheint bevor mir heute hilft ist
weiter da ich konnte drei unterschrieben
wurde und ich bin auch froh es ist
wirklich ich weiß nur dass ich selber
bin froh dass ich so bin wie für den
dank ihr und ihrer familie
[Musik]
es sind zwei verschiedene welten und
braut sind vor achteinhalb jahren das
herz trotzdem der ubs banker aus der
schweiz umweltpreis und
psychologiestudentin aus mexiko wie
seien sie aber sie hätte alles sehe
ihrem onkel hexe schon vor vielen jahren
prophezeit dass sie mal eine vorweg ich
sagte weißt du was ich werde einen
heiraten der mit mir die welt bereist
und der mit mir verrückte dinge tun
ich war noch ein kind als ich das sagte
und eines tages als ich mich mit dem es
auf machte erinnerte mich mein onkel
daran dass nun alles wahr geworden sei
[Musik]
ihre freundin franka will ich da ich
freue mich hier verliebt kann ihr
christlich und irgendwo duran ihm so
reiselust content rang 20 und nur mit
einer waldreichen befriedigen
und das hat sich mir der dusche keine
löschen die sich
nein sie kennengelernt haben woche saß
oft und sie mich wirklich hat wieder
begleitet hygienisches abend ihr und
obwohl sie mir von mexiko musik reißt
ist hat sie mich begleitet mit dem velo
von alaska bis auf mexiko zwar derzeit
keine velofahrer vor
und ich weiß dass ich die frage mit mir
durch dick und dünn gegangen
[Musik]
also was ich glaube damit am meisten
schätzt ist nun ihr personal ist so
vertraut
32 aber das haben wir so errichte raten
hohes lausigen dass er gezwungen ist
immer die wahrheit sagen und machen also
einfach ich konnte so einfach war es
auch merken aber es beschäftigt und das
ist schon schön und der passage wo dir
dass du das gefühl und das vertrauen hat
und frauen was schönes ich habe meine
schwächen erkannt nicht gut und es ist
und die sind einfach okay für die
naturschützer aber du musst nicht
vorwerfen dass wir ein von der reinste
manche wurden vom 5
[Musik]
nebst im landa winter ich gebe nur ihre
zweite spezialität berüchtigen mit viel
brotlose drüber das tor ist david zeige
ich sechs fasst david schaffte
unterdessen im kreis ihrer familie in
der hoch wie das der thomas noch keinen
job hat sieht er entspannt wenn er jetzt
noch nicht arbeiten will verstehe ich
dass er wird bestimmt eines tages etwas
finden dass er wirklich gerne machen
wir müssen das beide ganz entspannt
nehmen
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich dass ich ihn
unterstützen kann
es ist eine schöne gelegenheit ihm etwas
davon zurückzugeben was er mir gegeben
hat
der clou sind
und dann hast du bist dann heißt
niederschlagen
wände thomas winter finish ablauf der
frühling für seine schwiegermutter
schuss limette sogar eine programmiert
das habe ich für jocelyn gemacht hatte
ich da viel schneller als die andere
der frühere machen ich versteh ich mir
einfach schwierig war weist und die im
alter allein im auto die schwiegereltern
stehe also also muss sagt sie machen so
einfach wie möglich sich wirklich so
sehen wir die freiheit das hervorragende
die eu hat einfach was wir verlangen
verdient dass du wieder da bist aber
machen sind vize herzlich aber was sie
was ich bin ich bei internet zu sehen
mit der prämierung und hustet also
private partner moment war schon zwei
mal hinkriegen bis zum browser ist das
fällt natürlich alles weg was ich immer
blumen und das vermisse david rudisha
die moment war die nummer aus varel
engagements zur hand und darum werden
wir schon einmal leichen honig und
einfach mit dir aber eben zum arbeit
finden wo sie zuerst france bücher im
moment nur online
der lacht sich zumindest die temporäre
bewegung mitbewerber für französisch
kurs wo im kreis stattfinden und das
würde viel lieber online ist okay aber
fragen die das ist so wir sagen dir
einrichtet muss sie einfach durchziehen
muss ich warten bis sich zahlreiche
unterbieten verfolgen und hause schaut
einfach für die gerne machen liegt ganz
klar noch am plan machen das ist aber
eine sehr ist es aber das muss auch
funktionären plan macht aber da
natürlich hat auch er sehnt ist lena für
ihre jugend wo sich noch ändern
im system für die vom kommunismus oft
wachsen ist der leaf in die rezession
breit gemacht und die hände plant oder
zeuge arbeiter aus total runter drücken
ist scheiße ist dann hätten sie ihren
plan festgehalten obwohl schiffbruch
erlitten
und dass das ist klar sie sich zwei
jahre lang hat sie in dem system klebt
und das projekt sich morgen hält martin
und lana aber alles minutiös planen
sie sind unterwegs in die us-botschaft
bayern für planer als ukraine ist noch
nötig
24 6 grad
in keiner hinter applaus das ist alles
braucht und mit den ministern vertreten
ist also ja ich habe gedacht
ich habe gesagt dass es drei aber drei
wichtige und zwei mit der andere
dokumente alles perfekt kontrolle hätten
[Musik]
naja
ok und wie das so ok
[Musik]
einfacher machen ein grund warum die
etwas wie sie töten geht
[Musik]
okay okay
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hürden überwinden und neues anpacken
das nächste ziel von martin und ich
[Musik]
glaube wir ergänzen uns sehr gut
sie lernt von mir ich lerne von ihr klar
wir haben diesen kulturellen geb unsere
kommunikation ist unterschiedlich aber
wir versuchen unsere kulturen
gegenseitig kennenzulernen
[Musik]
zwischen haut ging jason brüder bobby
und seine frau kelly
[Musik]
als cola
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die beiden frauen studieren schon aus
festprogramm
es gibt sogar an wettbewerben es die
beide brühl dreht sich nicht so häufig
abu dhabi hat gemerkt dass der jailbreak
wunder hat war gut zu mir passt
brigit ist eine tolle persönlichkeit sie
ist sehr nett und passt ins leben der
indianer
sie war in der familie sofort akzeptiert
sie liebt gartenarbeit und sie kocht
sehr gut
sie ist naturverbunden und er ist durch
sie etwas ruhiger geworden
seine haare hat er zwar immer noch
[Gelächter]
chikinki
[Musik]
das ist
im alltag ich nehme viel übrig von der
indianische kultur verfrüht
umso liebevoller fleck mitglieder von
der stimmen die traditionen was man gibt
[Musik]
napster music manager mit indianischen
wurzeln zwei verschiedenen stellen
[Musik]
ich bin ruft jedes mal
[Applaus]
wenn brigit mit mehr tanzt wird mein
herz leicht ist überkommt mich auch eine
wehmut denn die frauen unseres stammes
tanzen nicht mehr regiert ist zwar nicht
native american aber sie ist meine
seelenverwandte
die leute akzeptieren dass das ist das
gute
wenn du die frau findest mit der eu
zusammen leben willst
sie ist die meine
wir glauben dass wir vorher zusammen
waren und für immer zusammen sein werden
wenn er im nächsten leben vielleicht
nicht in dieser form aber zusammen wir
sind einander vertraut wir gehören
zusammen
[Musik]
wie sie bei ruby der hund so einer quote
ausgetauscht und felix gottwald diesmal
aber mit mehr wünsche deiner beide teams
beste film des bundes wie mir jetzt mein
vater vor spanien die kritische stelle
ich bin in der schweiz geboren
die sagen ja ich bin italiener ja ich
bin spanier noch ein bisschen kleinlich
schwitzen
[Musik]
denn dem ist und nein sie sind auf
besucher der schweiz im davis in ihre
mutter sie hat sich damit abfinden dass
sie ihren sohn nur selten wurde dem ist
so gut sei ja alles im rucksack packte
und fällt 30
und dann noch ein ist immer länger und
länger und dann hat es auch nicht
natürlich danach verstummt das jetzt
irgend einem republikaner und überhastet
oder die schweiz oder die mexiko nein
sie unter dem ist island alles mit
social media
die wirklich großen moment im leben
[Musik]
ja
er selbst ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die menschen das sehen
der beruf machen
[Musik]
und so groß ist glück er gratulierte
nancy und demis und sind jetzt schon
gespannt wo sie es lieber als familie
hier für mexiko die tweets oder viel ist
aber ganz nah dann durch die die heißen
die beiden sowieso auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
warum hat er so viele kühe video very
fast das mal unter 8 milliarden menschen
der richtige verein selber finden ist
per se schon wundern
und wenn der eine oder die einzig auch
anderen handy von der welt wohnt
beinbruchs ganz normal leisten kann
dieses happy eingeht
riesig groß trug blieb wohl für immer
unbeantwortet was ist ein knackig braun
dazu bringt alles hinter sich zu und
jahr zeigen
so wird aus der thomas und david genau
an dem ort gemacht
[Gelächter]
vom winde verweht war schon seinen reiz
trug die trojaner und es bleibt ein dass
das treffen der schweizer schnitt sagen
ist ein zauberer stolz zuvor ist es
wirklich extrem gurk macht aber sinn
familie und meine familie und mich
verbindet und sich freuen dass ich
wieder rein die weg geht und das hin und
her und die sind zum teil monatelang
und wie man mit dem umgang sind ich
würde mir dass er seine gemacht was sie
treffen baske wir sind sehr stolz es gab
schöne augenblicke aber auch schwieriger
ich will nicht verheimlichen dass es
auch dieses spiel in situationen gab
dass wir es geschafft haben das macht
mich sehr stolz
posselt einfach super und der ganzen
dorfs gut würde dich immer und immer
wieder heiraten
[Musik]
was hältst du dir für eure gemeinsame
zukunft
ich wünsche mir dass wir uns nicht zu
viele sorgen machen dass uns die zukunft
nicht belastet dass wir zusammenbleiben
und dass es uns gut geht egal wo wir
leben werden
was ich mir wünsche ist dass ich es
schaffe da im gepäck sache platz finden
wo mich wirklich die high bin dass ich
geschichte aber und das ist das
das sei für die schweiz vor allem nach
gebäck und nach kanada
ja
[Musik]
der muslim
dj
[Musik]
nein
ich habe gesagt dass ich mich nicht
aufopfern musste wenn du glaubst dass es
laufe rung ist dann ist es keine liebe
liebe gibst du automatisch gerade noch
die kurve gekriegt
ich sage jeden tag ich liebe dich jeden
morgen
ich berühre sie immer wieder so bleiben
wir verbunden
wir beenden sogar gegenseitig unsere ich
liebe ihn so wie er ist
er ist gutmütig und er ist ein fachmann
sehr cool wenn in turin sprach rede
während sich nachher habe ich glücklich
wäre ich vielleicht mehr gegenüber ihren
männlichen russisch kontinuität passiert
ich denke mir anders machen und dann
wurde film schon fast fertig ist
erreicht ist vom anderen ende der welt
nur wunderbare nachricht als neuseeland
gibt es nachwuchs katja und erwartet
dass geschwister die für dich linien
aria
[Musik]
hin und weg meint luther manager keine
client wo zeigen dass wir die grenze und
hindernissen überwinden seien wirklich
vorbei aber ihre liebesgeschichte die
[Musik]
halloween
siemund vakzine präsentiert wurde
produkten